We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
This may be one of the craziest calls that
we've ever received.
Buckle up, folks.
Hey, precocious launch and grow.
Pair of you had a pair of shoes go back to
Venezuela.
Right.
Like it here.
Go back here.
Have my 14 year old daughter coming.
Take your own.
Yes.
Right.
I guess that's it.
Well, listen, I don't.
It's possible that your 14 year old daughter
is very, very strong and could kick my ass.
I don't know that.
I just haven't met her.
I'm not sure about that now.
I've never been to Venezuela and I've completely
condemned the Chavez Maduro regime.
We just have a new report out about the number
of deaths at the hands of the Venezuelan military.
Venezuela is not a place I've ever been to.
It is certainly not a place I'm going to anytime
soon.
So go back to Venezuela.
Seems like a real question mark.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about no protest zones.
We will talk about the real dog human age
multiplier.
And we're also going to talk about Michael
Cohen's spotted it at a Manhattan restaurant.
Allegations swirling about whether he needs
to be sent back to prison because of that.
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show.
Remember that next Tuesday is the third David
Pakman show chess tournament.
And our big July one day membership special
get on the newsletter at David Pakman dot
com to get notified about both of those exciting
events.